is definitely a bittersweet day here
lindsay's
last day i mean we're so happy for you
lindsay and we're going to miss you
thank you it's been amazing after
i've been here over 10 years my husband
12 13 years in vegas and we've decided
to move closer to my family in
pittsburgh we're really excited
but it's been a joy to work on this show
with you kendall and everyone else we
have such a great crew
and we're definitely going to miss it
here but we're also very excited to be
closer to family
so ah we're going to miss you so much
and to show you how much
we are going to miss you we put together
a little wheel a little
highlight reel of lindsay lou here at
las vegas actually from las vegas what's
even cooler
is this is my family that's my husband
that's my mom
no i'm pregnant y'all what
are you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey did you try those cookies that those
folks brought in oh
ted yeah we have a cookie for you those
are these are some of the best cookies i
have ever used from
this is from the um yeah
oh my gosh you guys kidding me that's
not a real cookie
it's soap rudy
rudy we're gonna get him inside we're
gonna get him outside we're gonna go
go go go oh we'll do some partner
dancing yeah yeah yeah so watch that
sweatshirt
like this watch this wait for it i'll do
this one wait for it go here
go around this way here this way boom
here and then oh my gosh hey
let's release some stress i don't know
this song
that was demolishing that pumpkin
um i do have some good news though
yeah baby
oh my gosh oh lindsay we're gonna miss
you so much thank you so much i really
appreciate it
you guys we'll get to see you every once
while
your husband has friends here in town
yeah we love vegas we're not going to
stay away forever that was really nice
you guys thank you
what is happening we are gonna miss you
so much
um but thank you for just bringing so
much joy here lindsay is one of the
kindest people
you're ever gonna meet and she brings
laughter and smiles every time she comes
in so a piece of us is going to be
missing uh at her departure but man
we're we're so happy for you that you're
going to be closer to family and
enjoying your home area i'm excited too
we can follow you on instagram still all
right lindsey gert
follow along thank you las vegas
picking you up